like
joe rogan with jamie it's a funny side i
didn't understand
how little joe knew about jamie when he
hired him
and jamie stepped up and now runs one of
the most successful
podcasts ever and that's an incredible
kind of
and he's one of the best producers in
the world now
not to let it get to his head and by the
way the funny thing about him and one of
the best googlers in the world about the
best googlers
the funny thing about jamie this is okay
you might not like this but what i what
i like
i'm constantly exceptionally
self-critical
to a point of like self-hating sometimes
i deeply appreciate every single moment
i'm alive but everything i've ever done
i feel like is [ __ ]
and when i talk to jamie about
everything he's done
he's so just in every way he carries
himself he's so self-critical
he's so like worried that it's wrong
it's bad
that anxious energy i love it
because that that's how you lead growth
and progress you might
like uh a therapist might say that's
probably not good for your like
well-being
[ __ ] it it's good for the
what's good for your well-being is to
create awesome things that's ultimately
what
leads to happiness is to to create the
best thing you can in your life
and uh so when i see that in in somebody
like jamie or
anybody i talk to when you're really
self-critical that's a good sign to me
is that ridiculous it's not ridiculous
at all and it goes back you know you
were
you were the way you were phrasing these
questions about what makes a good person
and what makes a good leader
the way you phrased them kind of
eliminated
the normal answer that i give the normal
answer that i give
you ask me what makes a good leader what
makes a good person
is is being humble
so when you're going to hire someone for
your
for your startup or whatever company
you're creating that is
a key characteristic to look for is
someone that has the humility
like like young jamie to say yeah you
know i
i could have done this better and here's
what i can improve and here's what i
need to work on
when you have somebody that thinks they
know everything um
out of the gate you're you're already
got someone that's gonna be hard to deal
with they're gonna be hard to coach
they're gonna be hard to mentor
when you have somebody that's truly
humble you barely again it's minimum
force required because
when you say to jamie after a show how
do you think that went he says well you
know i did this wrong and i didn't have
this set up in time and
you don't barely have to do anything
because he's got the humility if you've
got someone that's a big ego and you say
hey how did that show go he goes i went
awesome on my end
now guess what you have to do now you
have to start applying force as a leader
which is expending leadership capital
which we don't want to do because we
always try and
conserve our leadership capital as much
as we possibly can and when we have to
expend it just to get
jamie to make some improvements that's
bad
so when you go looking for people look
for people that are humble now does this
mean you look for people that don't have
any confidence no that's not what i'm
saying there's a balance to all these
things it's the dichotomy of leadership
you but people tend towards
and look i work with a lot of military
troops in the past
now i work with companies the reason i
talk about humility all the time is
because
for someone to be get into a leadership
position
in the military they have to have
confidence so the tendency is
that their confidence is going to
outweigh their humility at some point
same thing with with civilian companies
if you get to a point of leadership
inside of a company
you have to have confidence to get there
you don't get to a position of
leadership inside of a company
lacking confidence so the tendency is
for confidence to to grow a little bit
too much
and we have to put that put that
confidence into check we have to put
that ego in a check
really good leaders they're confident
but they're humble that's the balance of
the dichotomy
hear that jamie don't get cocky
you